autre technique la maison bio climatique
dans ce cas nous sommes dans une autre
logique c'est le tout écologique
j'en paye e clémence révèle sur toute la
hauteur pour créer une grande serre
pourrions et sud
lasserre c'est le premier élément de
cette maison bioclimatique à la fois
capteurs d'énergie solaire et espace
tampon entre le dedans et le dehors
autre critère l'isolation l'isolant est
placé entre le mur une crêperie cette
isolation bits par l'extérieur apporte
une protection maximum contre les
déperditions thermiques
troisième élément le puits canadien
cette bouche d'air alimente un tuyau
enfui à un mètre dans le sol une
profondeur qui procure une température
constante toute l'année autour de 16
degrés les habits bouche par cette
grille dont la serm monte gagne des
calories et réchauffe les pièces
le puits canadien peut fournir chaleur
ou fraîcheur le choix est fait deux fois
par an au changement de saison je passe
en commission
hiver donc je ferme cette arrivée là qui
amène de l'air du puits canadien et
j'ouvre cette arrivée qui amène air du
pont de la serre et donc échauffés par
la scène ici pas de radiateur d'un feu
de bois suffit l'alimentation de cette
cheminée à foyer fermé grâce à son très
bon rendement ne coûte que 15 100 francs
par an en injectant les autres usages
assurée par l'électricité la famille
dépense 5500 francs d'énergie par an
c'est 40 % de moins que ce que coûte une
maison classique comparables la
construction de cette maison cependant
entraîner un surcoût estimé à 60 mille
francs
on peut pas dire qu il pas sûr qu'on
pourrait être 5000 francs bon vu
l'économie qu'on fait mensuellement de
leurs 2 3 annuellement de 3,5 milles
francs on se dira que la période de
retour c'est dehors de 10-15 ans pour
rattrapée cet autre maison bioclimatique
en chantier une mise de systèmes
différents
un mur recouvert de peinture sombre
absorbant la chaleur très chaud offert
trois entrants l'extérieur quant à ces
grands panneaux solaires il alimente une
chaudière elle même source d'énergie
pour le plancher chauffant les
équipements qui ne fournissent pourtant
qu'une partie du chauffage pour pas
considérer qu'ils nous ont bien du match
il va permettre d'assurer 100% des
besoins on va faire une maison
bioclimatique pour couvrir jusqu'à 50%
des maisons et donc c'est pas
négligeable avec quelques centaines de
logements par an trois à quatre mille au
total en vingt ans la construction
bioclimatique reste marginal une aide de
l'état à ces maisons économes et
écologiques seraient assurément la
bienvenue